[Music]
it has been a very busy week at this
church there was a funeral held
wednesday at levi's garrison church of
the holy apostles peter and paul it was
a service for three fallen soldiers a
day before there was a funeral for two
and a day before that three more
[Music]
father nester kazeek admits being a
military chaplain at a time of war is
hard psychologically burying so many
young men or as he calls them boys
their lives that should have had many
years left this week they've had
soldiers who've just started families
some who were just married and one who
didn't quite make it that far
father kazek says one of the soldiers
had just proposed to his girlfriend and
then went to fight
now this church has a relationship with
the military that goes back three
centuries off to the side of this church
there are posters that the faces of
soldiers lost in a war that people here
will tell you didn't start two weeks ago
it began with the occupation of crimea
they've been adding posters here since
2014.
now they also have these boards this is
a war that's still being fought and
they're adding photographs of fallen
soldiers individually as they're killed
all this by the way and they still
haven't had the chance to put up the
soldiers remembered
was a 28 year old senior lieutenant his
fiancee and his close family attended
the military funeral in la vie but there
was another
grew up in a village about an hour
outside the city that entire village
came out to pay their respects
this man says
a patriot his loss the sacrifice of a
brave young man
[Music]
now in just two weeks the two sides in
this conflict have lost thousands of
soldiers those are statistics if you
don't have a name
everyone here on this day knew
at least one
mike armstrong global news la viv
ukraine